hails of guys my name is general welcome
to episode 16 of the Civilization series
this is the final episode this is it the
last episode the season finale of the
Civilization series so today we're going
to wrap up the series and we're going to
basically aim to do two things the first
thing is going to be to clean up the API
and clean up the code that we have and
see if there's anything we can do to
just make it a bit better right and
we're also going to see if there are any
other methods we would like to expose or
maybe other kind of utility and other
sorts of methods that we can create to
make our lives easier when using the API
right and and then we're going to jump
into an example and see how we can
actually use this this library here to
to serialize something in kind of a
real-world setting right so we'll create
like a little dummy game here it won't
really be a game or anything but we'll
create like the the skeleton for some
kind of game see if we can serialize
that out and I'm sure along the way
we'll we might we might find things that
we might find things that we can do to
our API to make it a bit easier to it to
achieve certain things so that's kind of
the idea we'll do all that stuff so
we'll start off with the API the things
that I wanted to address first of all
were these things right so we've got the
container types of other types they look
pretty good to me I don't think there's
anything we need to do with them but if
we go into like a civilization Rider for
example someone actually pointed out in
a comment that obviously this isn't
really a writer anymore it does a lot
more than just write stuff right it
actually writes are we even writing the
header in the version I just realized I
don't think we are oh we've got the hair
here does that's fantastic first of all
anyway um we should be writing the
header in the version so see this is
what I mean let's go through this and
see if we can kind of clean it up so
we've got the we'll delete that stuff
we're not using that anywhere anyway but
I will add a version right this will
just be a short two bytes should be
enough right we could do like a full
kind of major minor version
I don't really think that's necessary
especially for this scenario the other
thing that you have to do to make this
work right now is go into your serialize
or your get bytes method and just make
sure that we are in fact writing out
that version and then I'm also going to
make sure that in the reading side of
things I'm also going to read that
version and again we're going to do a
similar thing where we just basically do
read short and make sure that that kind
of shot that we read here is actually
equal to version right just to make sure
that we're on the right kind of thing in
fact I might even not really bring this
out as an assertion but say that if this
doesn't equal version then we basically
should return null and say something
like invalid version right and if I
might just put in something really quick
here invalid RC DB version and then
we'll return null okay but then
otherwise I mean we'll make sure that we
of course advance our pointer by the
size of a short which is two bytes and
we kind of go on let's just quickly run
that again we actually managed to get
ourselves into a crash somehow oh we
need to add that to the size of course
so there are a few things we need to do
here and there so I headed out at length
plus two plus one so now ok now we're
good
we get the same result as before okay
this is why we have like these tests
they're almost like unit tests right I
didn't setup really unit tests here just
because that would have taken a bunch of
extra time but definitely setting up
unit tests in this scenario would be a
fantastic idea because there are a lot
of things that you kind of need to watch
for whenever you change the structure of
this stuff and even having like non non
official unit tests which is kind of
what this is is also a pretty good idea
okay anyway yeah so this is more or less
like sterilization utils I'll call it
okay I'm just going to refactor that I
hit alt shift are there or if you
right-click here go to refactor then
rename you will be able to rename
that class it doesn't really matter
because we are using it's statically
everywhere so it's not a big deal but we
could do something like this and we now
have all of our kind of utility methods
right on in here
cool so anyway I forgot to say that I
think we had a problem with this stuff
and we had to get this as an in what was
that all about because I remember and
there was something wrong with that that
required us to do this stuff oh yeah
that was the whole issue of the bike
being negative I think that this should
probably be replaced anyway so if we
just wrap this as a two and then I say
get sure we'll just kind of do this
everywhere and just make sure that we're
good
read bullying's so was this if it was
like packed I guess oh this was a
boolean array of course this is the
arrays
okay so we'll delete that read long
again we'll just become this make sure
we have eight bytes here and then yeah
like this stuff is pretty good we can
just convert the in bits and stuff I
hope that this will kind of carry across
well I'm sure it will anyway um
there we have it that looks pretty good
to me just cleaning up some stuff here
and there now the big thing that I
wanted to clean up was the fact that
I'll see object and RC field and all
this stuff they all have the same kind
of well they'll have names for example
and they all kind of have the same set
name get name kind of methods and it's
just kind of getting a little bit
annoying having to deal with all a so
I'm gonna make a new class called
RC base right
and then RC base is going to be kind of
the base class going to be I'm not sure
if I'm making an abstract class but
basically I'm just going to make it so
that all this stuff kind of
extends from this base class so field
and object and string right and then I
will move this yet name set name all the
way to base so where's base here right
and then of course I'll also move stuff
like the what I just move that from so
this can now get deleted
I'll also move stuff like name and a
name length out of here all this stuff
is going to have a name anyway
just like that okay this should probably
be private I'm and and I think we'll be
getting that too often in fact we were
we wouldn't be getting this at all I
imagine and then for the size as well is
something that we'll have to carry
across so the way that we're going to do
size is going to be a bit different
because I imagine as you can imagine the
size is something that it's kind of
delicate so basically like the size is
going to like the size is going to
contain just the name here and all this
kind of one plus two plus whatever
that's not really going to stay the same
we're going to set the size to two
meaning that it does indeed carry name
length okay and then when we go out of
that we'll have to calculate everything
kind of again so if we go back to our C
object and we have this size here right
I'm going to copy this real quick I'm
gonna kind of recalculate it here real
quick so we have the container type we
have the name is that's kind of moved
out of this class now so we only care
about stuff is in this class and the
size of course is four four bytes here
and then we have field count string
count and all that stuff with it so this
size is pretty accurate okay so all
we're gonna do is want to cut that and
put it into the into the constructor and
that is all we have to do okay and then
the size of course will be set correctly
we probably want to also move this into
the other constructor I imagine let me
just see what we got here
yes I guess new Oscar is how we really
great stuff so we'll set the size there
I don't think this size actually needs
to get set because it will this is the
deserialized version so we'll kind of
leave it like that but that is kind of
and this should be particles right and
then this is going to kind of just
append all the extra stuff we have here
to the base size which is only the size
for this base class right besides the
actual size variable should be here as
well so it should really be 2 plus 4
because we've got 2 bytes for the short
and 4 bytes for the end so back out here
we can get rid of that int and there we
have it
okay so this should be the this size
should be exactly the amount of fields
we have here okay now this size offset
thing was just a test that we used I
think it's not actually use anyway so we
can remove that for now especially
because us moving the size around like
that does somewhat invalidate it okay
cool
so when we write out this stuff this
should all be protected of course we
shouldn't really have any problems with
any of that good let's move on to ask
the array so ask the array of wall so
extend our sea bass will delete that
will move the size into the constructor
which was gonna have to be here in this
case there's plus a equals of a
container type we've got the type which
is a byte as well we've got the count
which is an int and then we've got a
bunch of other stuff so let's see so
this is all we have I felt like we had
more one plus one plus four I want this
one before I think that's actually it
let's take a look at what we actually
wrote out so one that's taken care of
plus one plus yeah okay cool so one plus
one plus four setname getname can get
removed of course which is the whole
point of this thing and that is looking
pretty good to me okay so I see field is
next
doesn't even have a size ah this is feel
right so I guess the size doesn't really
get written out at all here okay but
obviously name length and name can still
get removed as can get name and set name
and then I think we're good okay cool
ah yes yeah so there we go that's fine
and then what else do we have our C
string so we can get rid of name like
the name okay this does have a size so
let's move that into the only
constructor that we have so size is
going to be plus equals 1 for the
container type 4 for the count and that
looks like it's that's it so we went
from having to plus 4 which was the
count of us are the name length and the
size to just getting rid of them
obviously because we only really have
those two in here okay cool is that it I
think that might be it does this have a
get name and set name let's go get
string which is different nothing to do
with name I guess we moved it out of
this class already cool I think that's
it ok let's just take it out for a spin
see what we get ok Crash's that's I mean
that's expected
looks like we've wrote out the size
wrong or something like that
I'm not 100% sure I just really want to
make sure that we're not actually
constructing that here or anything like
that because there might be and that
would result in problem so this is a
problem when we're actually serializing
data that's interesting
so maybe database gets I just returned
the wrong size where do we set a size
here and we don't okay yeah that's
important so why did I not name like the
name oh we didn't do if a database
that's important kind of most important
thing okay so let's grab this size and
let's set this to the public version
so sighs plus equals had a length to the
version then we have one for the
container type then we need for we're
inside of course so just to think if
again we get rid of two plus four there
let's run that again okay still array
next out of bounds destination I'm
guessing we didn't allocate in our space
is probably what's happened yeah I
assume so
okay database get size does return size
we are doing plus equals how do we
create the database so let me just check
that ok just buy a new database what is
using this constructor cool set name
we'll just append the name length to the
size which is two plus four
okay that that's that's correct and then
we have so did hang on hang on a minute
right bytes and that is a short value
this failed how is that even possible
we ran our c object okay so weren't okay
and that makes more sense yeah so i
don't know what went wrong here but
definitely excited to find out alright
so after a bit of digging it was very
very subtle mistake on my part when i
set the size and our C string I assigned
it to one plus four instead of adding
one plus four to it because of course if
we just assign it then we overwrite the
extra six bytes we have for the name
length and the size so very very
delicate operation of course but if we
run that now we should it should be the
same as before
okay so cool let's add all let's add
back all of our things and sterilize the
whole thing see how that works looks
pretty good to me
okay great so there we have it we did
quite a bit of cleanup there we made as
a ski base class that contained
basically I think everything that we
really kind of share in common in terms
of the name at least
and then of
the size whilst that isn't used the size
that we have in our sea bass is used by
everything's a field and that's fine
because you can see field has its own
kind of get size thing that just returns
that we could like spend some other time
like well we could do some other things
such as maybe make make this an abstract
class and then do something like public
and getsize public abstract and get
sighs just making sure that everything
has a guest size but you know I mean
there's really no point to do that like
I'll leave it in here because I already
done it but there's a really not much
point to that because I don't think that
will be referring to these things as
like our sea bass or something very you
know like when we make a database or
something I don't think we'll be doing
something like like that ever really
right because that's just a little bit
weird like will always be referring to
these as you know a database or an
object or a field or whatever so there
we have it that's a bit of cleanup there
I don't think I want any anything else
from the API side so let's kind of get
rid of this and see if we can create a
cool little scenario in which we
serialize and deserialize things so I'll
literally get rid of I don't want to
really get rid of it I think I'll just
think I'll just make a new class inside
out our test here called sandbox and
then so this will be kind of little a
little sandbox for us so this is our
standards over there and deserialization
test they will have a new sandbox and
then we'll have something fun like
sandbox dot play so can play in the
sandbox why not okay cool so we'll have
a class in here called entity I think
that's usually a good way to go and we
might have a class called like play or
something so I'm kind of trying to think
up of a cool little real-life kind of
experience that we can kind of play
around with so if we have an entity in a
player class you know the stuff that the
player would the entity might have like
private index
I have a name maybe like will have also
have a level class so we might have like
these kind of details and something like
Oh rotten oh man we might have something
like what else is an NT how I show open
up the game programming series and see
but I think we've got that's mainly the
important stuff like well we'd probably
even have names but we do have other
things like whether always removed for
example which we don't really care about
because if it's if the MC like if we had
a boolean called removed like we do for
example in the game program it doesn't
really matter because we definitely
won't be sterilizing stuffers that has
been removed because they'll actually be
deleted from the level anyway the next
update so player might have some
additional things like I don't even know
I hate coming up with stuff on the spot
but player might have some additional
things such as oh well you know level
will have entity level level as well and
probably internet public void in it
which will kind of do the same thing as
it is there there's not levels level
player might have a I was gonna say
player might have a name and indices
might not you might have like a sprite
or something I don't know private string
Avatar path which might be like I don't
know something and then when we can
start to play you know we might want to
make a player at a certain location into
X&Y
we might set the name to like name so
we'll save this dot name equals name and
put that in here just make this stuff
protected real quick this dot name
equals name
okay hope this what x equals x and goal
that stuff will of course make this role
of this actually extends entity avid
apart Avatar path might be something
like res avatar dot PNG I don't know I'm
just guessing at this point and this is
kind of the the way that it'll all get
set up and then level of course will
have like a list of entities it might
have like a add method it might have you
know our static kind of update render
whatever I'm just adding some stuff here
so it looks more legit level might have
sorry a width and a height
file path something like that so that
when we like make a level you know we
give it the path we might even give it
something like I'll just say path we
might even like you know in a real
scenario we'd probably do it like read
the width and height from from the level
file but in this case we'll just put in
some fake values so anyway we've got
this kind of situation here I think
that's pretty good in our sandbox or in
play or something we might make an
entity like a mob which would just I
guess and she doesn't really have a
constructor of it so this also do a dot
in it this will also have something like
maybe an entity constructor which just
sets X to 0 Y to 0 this should already
be 0 anyway but we'll just have like a
constructor there for fun so we'll have
like a mob for example we might have a
player show no that's let's just say 40
28 and then let's just say we make a new
level level dot lvl or something leveled
up AdMob level dot add player ok cool so
I think that's decent oh yeah that's
what we've pretty much got there anyway
so let's just say that we want to
serialize the level so we say level
they'll save res or I'll just call it
level dot rain cloud database ok so how
do we serialize all this data that we
have here ok how do we say about that
level well glad you asked so the way
that we'll do it is well let's see how
we'll do it I'm not a hundred percent
sure yet so I guess we'll have our path
right
remember this is supposed to be as
simple as possible if I refer back to
our tests it looks like we just managed
to do something like okay so we had a
safety file so this safety file stuff
could probably be moved into the actual
database I imagine so our C database it
has this utilized from file will have
serialized true file I guess this'll
just be low case it won't be static
either
and it'll just have a path and then what
we'll do is we'll write the data that we
write here we'll probably have to create
that so we'll say byte data equals new
by to get size and then we'll say
something like get get by its
destination being data point of being a
zero and then we'll write divert out
okay so that's pretty simple it's
utilized to see really has to file
should work pretty well for us so if we
go back to main and we can adjust what
we've got here so instead of saved to
file or anything and then having to
create this stream or whatever we should
just be able to say database
they'll sterilize to file test up our CD
okay so let's say we went with our
cities that have a seat
DB there anyway yeah so that'll be
easier to do we don't have to do
anything in terms of actual file writing
ourselves we'll kind of let the database
take care of that
so back out here so our CD if we just
leveled up save that ideally what we
probably want to do is realize
everything so in the save method here's
what we'll do we'll make a database
let's also give this a name so in this
case we'll just say something like level
one
so we'll say I've I'll see database
database equals new asset database we
might call this like level or something
level save level data will also say so
here's what we'll do we'll create an
object the other thing that I think I
forgot to mention was that I don't think
objects can have other objects in them
right now so that's something that you
might want to add again totally up to
you but we'll probably do something like
we'll have older level data in the again
it totally doesn't matter it just
depends how you see the data if you kind
of see it as a tree of objects then it's
totally fine to make it so the database
is a nested inside database is if you
just see it as like a flat list like as
it's just a flat array rather than a
tree then you don't need that nesting
ability so it's not really a matter of
what's possible or what not anything
that is that you do with the tree is
going to be possible with a flat list
it's just the trees of course a much
better data structure if you want to go
to a specific leaf and you know the path
to get to that leaf right whereas if you
look at level what we've really got is a
flat list anyway so in this case having
objects inside objects probably isn't
the best idea so we'll have level data I
might actually have the database as the
level so I might actually just say name
okay and then what I'm really going to
do is I'm going to go through every
single entity we have here in our
entities list and I'm going to say I'm
gonna create an object out of it
so object so I'll see over to MC equals
a new policy object string name now this
is where it gets interesting
we could use the entity's name entities
don't necessarily have names though so
instead you really could call this
anything you want like I could for
example call this entity plus and then
be like index of the array I might
actually do that so we'll say in I
equals 0 is less than entities dot size
I plus
and I'll say we'll create a new object
the actual entity is going to be
entities get I it doesn't really matter
because remember the reason I keep
saying it doesn't really matter is
because this is on this is literally
just the reverse of when we actually
load it you just need to know you just
need to choose a way to save it so that
you know how to load it
so we'll say something like e + I right
so we have that entity and I guess the
fact that we have a number here as well
probably it also tells us which
arraigned X it is of course we could
also say like entity dot add field RC
field dot so let's say what like a
integer for example that just has the
name being the array index and then the
value being I so we could also store
that if you don't want to have to pass
this string or something but anyway
other than that we'll probably say
something like rather than having to
create something like this every single
time we'll probably more or less say
something like our C object entity
equals e dot serialize a dot serialize
right and then this stuff we can kind of
say you know what this stuff is going to
be moved into so serialize into entity
right so again here we could either say
that this is actually something that
returns an RC object but it's usually
better because of course the antes lists
in the level they need the context of
the level so I like actually writing
this as a void and then having it take
in and I'll see objects I kind of like
what I did in the other thing right and
then all this will do is it'll kind of
add everything to it so we might have an
overriding player that adds these extra
fields but anyway the reason this works
so well is because it means that I can
just over here I can just say I want to
serialize I can still have my new RC
object I know
which index it is in the array so I can
have something like that okay when I
serialize it I just need to pass an
entity and then of course I can add
extra things such as you know these
fields for example so I might add that
in first and then over here the reason
it works so well is because when I write
stuff like object dot add field RC field
dot integer so we have X we have Y we
have I guess we'll add that boolean just
for lulz but we don't really need it so
bullying removed and then we don't
really realize the level of course the
reason this works so well is because
when I do since we're not returning a
new object when I do something like this
it's very easy to just say that actually
we're going to run super dull serialize
object right and then we'll just add on
the stuff that we were missing and you
could do that like before or after up to
you so for example I guess I'll do it
after but we'll add in the name of the
avatar and the avatar path
so we'll say object dot add field all
right that's actually more of a string
for the strings so add string RC string
dot create so name will be name
the data will be data or a name rather
and then we'll do the same thing for the
avatar path
okay so we've civilized that daughter
out and that's all good now right when
we run that serialize it will just run
the super in serialize the based stuff
like XY and removed and also all the
other stuff as well and then what we
have here is basically now a collection
of entities that have all the data that
we want okay so if we actually do at the
end of this when we've kind of run all
this stuff and it's all worked out great
we can just say database so I'll
sterilize the file and pause okay and
that's all we have to do so you will
have to add sterilized methods of course
we're not using reflection or anything
like that so we don't we don't know the
fields so it's generally you you will
have to manually sterilize H field like
this that's pretty normal though like
reflection is not the greatest thing in
the world either especially in terms of
performance it definitely makes your
life easier and will probably lead to
less mistakes but it's uh it's this kind
of this is like the old-fashioned way of
doing things and it definitely it
definitely works very well so just make
sure that you don't forget things the
other thing is I guess will sterilize
this level stuff as well so I might add
an Aussie object at the beginning
I'll see object dot all I think is just
new RC object right so level data for
example and then we might say something
like object did I didn't add these to
the database either did I make sure you
do database dot add object entity okay
so we might do something like object dot
I had filled RC filled dots I guess
we'll do the two integers which is width
and height of the level again these
aren't things that you would typically
sterilize because the level the actual
level would be a will be loaded from its
own level file only they don't know only
the dynamic things would have to be kind
of appended here but I guess we'll do
the name of the path as well so object
dot and string D string dot create so we
have the name
we have the path again it's just an
example we'll add that object to the
database okay cool so there we have it
that looks pretty good to me I think
that's it so let's try running this so
I'll comment out this I'll just do
sandbox play let's run that okay we
didn't get a crash that's that's step
one that's good let me just quickly
bring up the actual serialization thing
I have no idea where that is there here
is found it all good so here it is we've
got level our CD so we'll quickly open
that in hxd okay so what we have we've
got our CD bit about the version number
we've got basically you can see level 1
then we've got level data with high you
know name there's a name level 1 we've
got the the path which is just level
lastly of what whatever I don't even
know what we set the path to be I think
level level right I also want something
like that path oh yeah ok so there it is
fine let's see then we have B and C 0
and C 1 whatever we got they have it up
avatar path I don't really care about is
this stuff is kind of meaningless if we
had some kind of sterilization viewer
then that would be totally cool because
then we could maybe make like a you know
we'd have like a tool if this was
actually using the game we'd probably
have some kind of tool to kind of would
let you see these things in an actual
you know kind of jty that we made so we
can easily see the data and it was
deserialized everything for us but this
looks like it has everything we want
anyway so let's do the reverse of that
now let's actually load hopefully
everything here based on what we have
here ok so this kind of relies on us
knowing what we want to do as well right
as I said it is like this isn't really
like we need to know that the first
object is a level object like as in the
subject is level data object which has
everything in it we could obviously not
write these out in the right order and
we could just do something like a data
base get me the object that's called
level data but the truth the fact the
matter is you know we need to know that
there is an object called level data and
that it has all these fields that we
want that's just how it works I think
that the biggest thing that we don't
have though is that actual facility in
our API to find objects so we should
definitely have something like public
our C object find object string name and
then all this is going to do is go
through every single objects okay
see if the name if the name of the
objects object our name or rather object
of get name dot equals name if true then
it'll just return the objects otherwise
return no right we a similar thing in
terms of our fields as well and now
everything else pretty much so RC RC
object rather I should have this stuff
that we kind of want here such as find
field by name right RC field field
fields right and then etc right I guess
I will add the rest though because they
are kind of important find array find
string I think a razor lost anyway I say
so find string of course return an RC
string
the other thing that we could do is
obviously this get name is something
that appears in every single RC base so
we could just have a generic find RC
base and then cast it to what we want
this is just a little bit more robust
though because we don't really know what
this is it's not storing any kind of
type we could obviously move container
type from string since everything has a
container type 2 RC base but yeah I'm
not really fond of that idea anyway
back into RC object which is somewhere
here here it is
we'll just finish this up real quick so
find array will return that array array
and there we have it okay so we can kind
of find everything now which is good
because now we don't really need to know
anything we don't really need to know
the order in which we serialize anything
but basically what we'll do is the other
thing that's actually kind of important
by the way is if we decide on a format
such as in our what am I looking for
sandbox in our sandbox if we decide on
something like having a in an index it's
probably also a good idea to quickly
just serialize a field here that is the
amount of entities that we have so RC
field integer entity count entities the
size right and if we just do that it'll
make our life kind of looping through
everything a lot easier cool so we've
got a save so we'll have a public level
load string path okay so I'll see
database database equals RC database dot
e serialize from file
there's our path and then basically so
the first thing we're looking for is of
course that past the object which has
our data so object level data it will
start a base dot find object level data
and then once we've got that we can
begin setting our I'll think so level
result equals new level so this is why
you always have to have some kind of
default constructor and in this case
we'll have a private level constructor
here that's just used for recreating
stuff from a savegame
we'll set result up with equal to level
data dot find field the other thing is I
wonder how we'll get the data from the
field and I think we've really covered
that out where we just print out the
field yeah that's another thing we need
to talk about but anyway when we find
the field so width I believe is the
field we really need to actually know
because we get the field back but how
can we actually cast it into the right
data right like if it's a short this is
us creating everything where do we do
serialize this we've to see realized
this so we've got the data here but we
don't actually know what daughter it is
like we do know by the type but that's
that's about it so there are a few ways
you could go about this it's totally up
to you
the best way I mean I'm just thinking
you could definitely probably write this
as a template but let's say let's see if
we can just do something like public and
get int and then all this will do is it
will return read int byte source being
data and pointer being 0 all right
that's this that's the simple way of
doing this so we have to know what type
it is
right we can always check to see what
type it is but but from that we can't do
much and the thing is though you need
you do need to know what type this is
right like you did field the width
whilst you could ask it what type it is
there's no way to just be like oh you
know give me an auto type or something
like this I don't know what type it is
you do need to know what type it is so I
think something like get int is totally
reasonable so that's for example how we
get that we'll fill this out for the
rest of the things really quickly so I
get bites get shot get short reach I
just want to check real quick that I get
a short comes before chart in our
chronological ordering here so I'll
quickly reorder that short int is there
good long double float boolean is all
that remains double float bullying of
course we have to actually change the
return type obviously I didn't even
think about that
so see this is great because having a
real world usage like this means that we
can kind of do this also it means this
videos going to be huge but I didn't
want to pack everything into this one
because it is a finale ok there we have
it and that's everything
this will just be returned data 0 ok so
now we can do that we've got the width
the height whoops again you don't need
to generally need to look through
everything like I could be like hey you
know a database give me your list of
fields I know don't give me a list of
objects I know that the first object is
going to be the level data so thus give
me you know and I also know the order of
the fields because we do know this I'm
just showing you a more kind of
universal use case right well we might
not know this stuff so we've got the RC
strings that we need to set up as a
result dot result dot name right equals
level data dot find string the name will
be name I think right and then this will
just be get string then we'll do the
same thing for the path I'm just going
to double check you up now and path
okay so we have all that level kind of
metadata here the entity count is last
one okay we don't really care about that
as in it that's not something that we
store and she counts okay so now we just
have to go through entity counts and you
know we could again one way of doing
this would be something like I'll see
object entity equals database dot find
object with the string a plus I you know
totally fine not necessarily the worst
thing in the world remember we do know
this though like we could this that's we
could obviously just say something like
hey you know let's we know that we have
X amount of entities we know that
there's an offset of you know one so
let's say that the offset is like one
being because the first object is level
data so one plus I and then we could
just do something like hey you know
fetch me you know my entity is just
going to really be database dot objects
get offset done that's my object no kind
of finding a no string concatenation or
anything required whatsoever totally
fine you have all your data here
that's absolutely acceptable and that's
the way I would probably do it however
if you don't know what order your
database is in for some weird reason
then or maybe it's a larger database
then this is something that you could do
and it will work as well probably a
little bit slower or in this case we we
definitely won't notice the difference
so when I create my entity
I again I've got my object so similarly
how we had that sterilized we just need
to have a public static entity D
serialize RC object object where we'll
just create a new entity okay I guess we
do have a constructor here which is fine
and then we'll just say you know like X
for example is going to equal object dot
find field again you could add stuff to
your objects like object I'll get int
immediately and then it'll just find a
field that is an integer with the name
that you give it and then automatically
call the dog get into it and that will
be much better than having to go through
this but you know what else
so we'll say dot it's a fun field dot
get int and sorry this will be result
dot X result on Y it was all talk
removed so this is a boolean finally
otherwise I've got a lot of integers
everywhere this is removed okay and then
that's all that we've really wrote so
we'll just return results of course this
will also be the other thing that
happens so this will be a bit more
complicated because we don't know if
something is a player or not but it will
still be fine so numerous ways to do
this we could just get the entity first
so we could say entity dot deserialize
object which we'll just get out and get
all of the fields that we need right and
then we could just read them by saying
player results with new player
quickly make a private constructor here
okay so we've got that and then of
course we can set result on X equal to e
dot X Ito why you don't removed
okay and now we've gotten part that
passed that we can set the player
specific things so the players Pacific
things are just the two strings really
so result of name is going to be object
I cannot write anything today object dot
find string name dot get string probably
should override to string as well that
might be confusing but anyway result
dots we could just make like tooth
string or something return return guest
string okay
there we go so we've got everything
result is a player so this should be
happy maybe what I guess I need to make
this static
yeah okay cool so there we go
that's how we do that the one thing that
I probably probably should should store
here as well when we see realize this is
what type the entity is now in this case
we have no idea what type the entity is
right so we could say something like hey
if entity if E's instance of player then
we'll still something like and T dot
will will always have to store this
anyway but we'll say that
int you know type equals zero if each
instance of player type equals one and
then we'll obviously add in a field we
can just make this a byte that says type
and type okay just something like that
so that we can we know who what we need
to do serialize what is wrong with you
string byte okay so type is not advice
there we go
okay great so back here when we dis
realize this stuff will get a fine
object and this is what we'll do the
first thing is we've got that so we can
just check the type real quick
so if entity dot get or sorry if if
entity don't find field type get bytes
equals one then we know that the we're
dealing with a player
so we'll say entity e a equals RC or
rather equals player dot deserialize
entity
else a equals entity LTC lives and then
at the end we'll just say entities or
result of entities don't add 8 ok right
so that should be it and then at the end
we can of course return that but the
point is we've we now have reconstructed
a level from a file ok
which probably test this so I guess I'll
run this again just so it Cyril eise's
everything great now we'll do the
reverse so we won't give it anything
here we'll just say level dot
deserialize which is another thing go
ahead and make a static it's called Lord
actually so this needs to be static as
well so level dot Lord path will be
level or as leveled up level I don't
actually know if the rest of all that
was created
I guess or wait a win it no it's just
that so we probably get rid of this
let's just serialize that one more time
make sure that that's actually good ok
so yeah so we should but just by this
one line here we should be serializing
everything so if we quickly run this
I'll probably have to put a breakpoint
here if we run this oh that's it
that is a bad crash the system can't
find the file specified really really
you can't find the file refresh aw it's
OCD what did I say it was Auto lvl oops
oh because I was fake loading it from
yeah yeah yeah sorry
this was res flash level OCD ok we
should probably handle that more
gracefully by the way that file not
found thing but anyway level lower
okay we hit our break point which is
good so we didn't crash in the
deserialization let's take a look at
that level object look at that so the
name is level 1 the width and height is
64 1 to 8 the path is leveled on our CD
which i think is wrong I don't know why
as well it's because when we serialize
this the path that we wrote was path and
not their stop off so let's quickly just
try that again
so the path should be res level so let's
just stop that real quick and come back
here so this is kind of the first test
I'll just put this around it so that we
aren't have to create unique variable
names okay so level I was going to debug
in fact level we have the name being
level one we have the path as what we
set it to right we have the width 64 the
high at 1 to 8 and we have 2 entities of
cause one of them's a player with the
app to help half that we have name is
Cherno we didn't initialize the entity
that's the only thing we haven't done
which is why this is null but we have
our entities set up here which is great
so there we go
that's how we can serialize and
deserialize stuff it works really well
as you can see all we need to do in this
case is just call level load and it'll
load it'll restore everything from our
save file okay which is pretty awesome I
didn't check the players location that's
the last thing I probably should have
done let's just check that real quick or
in fact before we do that let's quickly
say that instead of calling result dot
where do we do this instead of calling
result dot entities that of course we
should just do result on add and that
we'll just add it as as if it was you
know properly added so now we have
entities we've got two entities of
course we've got one of those err player
we've actually got the level in there
now which is nice and then the player's
coordinates x and y hopefully 40 and 28
which is what we set them to yeah
fantastic so there we go that is the end
of the Civilization series hope you guys
enjoyed this if you did please the like
button for the final
episode in this huge episode almost now
along and yeah so next time I guess
we'll jump back into game programming
I'll put this on github by the way the
link will be in the description below if
you want to check this out on github all
the code for this entire series will be
there and yeah if you guys enjoyed the
video please don't forget it to hit the
like button and I'll see you guys next
time goodbye